hey guys I'm Ryan Higa say your name hey
I'm Brad there you go there you go and
we're gonna be watching the trailer for
Adam Sandler and Drew Barrymore's new
movie I think it's called blended and we
all know how much everyone really
respects that I'm Sam and I love Carrie
oh yeah yeah me too really close to each
other all right let's do this
my name is Jim I'm Lauren got your
shrimp with sauce on the side it's time
I should be spending with my kids wanna
shoot some hope what do you want she's
not interested in you believe me Frodo I
don't like her either
restaurant mixed up our cards Oh it's
over between me and dick now nobody gets
to go where was he gonna take you
Africa this is the last name theodopolis
yes that's my boss my boy would give
anything to go on a vacation like this
mr. theodopolis
hi it's Jim I wonder if you'd be willing
to sell me the vacation wait until they
tell the boys way to like tell the girl
don't tell my dad like that butthole
language is a puddle she wants to not
you
have you ready for the most romantic of
your entire life situation the movie
looks a lot better than most Adam
Sandler movies that looks funny
I like 51st days a lot yeah they're good
tienen I'm waiting singer that was good
you do better more still hot yeah I
think so she's good like that cute and
hot yeah yeah she's like a combination
of cute and hot she's mostly cute I
would go with that yeah but she is Priya
yeah I'm still wondering you know hey
thank you we'll enter